des poutrelles d'acier mastiquer et
peintes de couleurs blanches des lignes
raffinées
cette pièce est réalisée en 2010 par
nicolas sale un sculpteur et l'on
courtois elle fait partie d'une série de
trois dans les deux premières lignes
sont posés quasiment identiques et la
troisième ligne vient changer la forme
de la pièce et la perception de la
sculpture c'est une oeuvre qui qui
seront format horizontal due à la
période de deux voyages fait dans le
nord à dunkerque où j'avais fait une
résidence et ce qui n'avait intéressé
c'est aux autres de réfléchir sur la
notion de l'espace n'est pas dans l'air
tk limité mais dans son horizontalité
vendredi 30 mars changement de
physionomie
les 800 kg de lèvres sont sur le départ
direction le grand palais à paris pour
une exposition d'art contemporain
programme pas la première fois et là
c'est une semaine passionnante parce
qu'on va rencontrer des collectionneurs
des professionnels du public
on va pouvoir parler du travail la
visibilité
voilà c'est un doux moment ils volent
semaine assez assez pauvre pendant
quatre jours nicolas sanhes partagera le
monument parisien avec plusieurs autres
artistes près 2000 créateurs participent
à art paris art fair